health officials in china are trying to
identify mysterious string of pneumonia
china ordering a quarantine for the
entire city of wuhan
where the contagious corona virus was
first detected
and is spreading fast
detected or suspected in at least 11
countries across the globe
concerns of a global pandemic are
spreading from a virus
that's now reached the united states
the washington state man has died from
coronavirus the first
death from that disease here in the u.s
the nba is now urging its players
to avoid high-fiving fans major event
organizers and cities face the difficult
choice of whether to cancel
big public events the nba is telling
teams they should be prepared
for the possibility of playing games in
empty arenas
the teams insisted they won't play
without fans if i show up to arena ain't
no fans in there
i ain't playing i mean we just got to be
prepared for anything and at the same
time
keep leaving keep doing what we do nba
mlb
nhl mls banning all non-essential
personnel from their locker rooms until
further notice
golden state warriors confirming they
will play without fans tomorrow night
march madness will also be closed to the
general public
today the world health organization
officially calling it a pandemic
there's a regular road trip rudy and i
we generally sit across the aisle from
each other
royce manuel and beaujon behind me and
then mike behind
right john tucker
got there the night before we were
pretty excited for this game
just ready to go
we knew rudy was going to be out for the
game he's you know feeling a little bit
sick
when we get to the game we warm up
everything is going real smooth and next
thing you know you see a bunch of guys
and
suits run out
[Music]
i thought it was the fbi
you knew something was going on as soon
as
you looked out on the court i was two
rows from the court
you saw people that you usually don't
see during that time of the game you saw
the thunder's assistant general manager
talking to officials their team doctor
donnie strack
who was also talking to officials
there was so much confusion so many
little red flags as an nba reporter
that said something is different and
wrong
i got a call from the league office fans
were in the seats
ready to go we were now five or ten
minutes past the point we were supposed
to tip
i've been part of game delays before it
was like a leak coming out of the
ceiling so it really felt like that
outside of the guys rushing the floor
[Music]
we were just told we just got to go back
i walked back thinking all right we'll
be back out in like 45 minutes
at first we'd heard from an oklahoma
city television reporter that law
enforcement was on their way to the
arena to help evacuate and so our first
indication was
is this a bomb threat
then we got to the locker room we were
told rudy had it
on that point we were kind of just
silent
that's where it became scary
unforeseen circumstances the game
tonight has been postponed
you are all safe thank you for coming
out tonight
good night fans
our champs terrania at the athletic
actually broke
the news that rudy gobert had
coronavirus
in that moment we made the decision we
should be taking
a hiatus there was no hesitation there
was no
call to the board of governors there was
no consultation with anybody
adam silver just shut the lake down
this is crazy this can't be true i mean
it's not within the realm of
possibilities it's just to seem more
like out of a movie than reality
i honestly thought we were going to be
like all right we're going back to the
hotel
then to come to find out the hotel that
we stayed at was under lockdown
no hotels would take us
we're sitting down kind of outside the
door
where the players leave and you're
seeing health officials come through
with boxes
when i saw them come in with their suits
and equipment and
masks stuff we see today all right this
is like
the real deal
the reporters that travel and cover the
team we're in direct contact with these
players all the time we're
in very close proximity talking right
next to their faces
they got us all tested including the
team and the traveling party and
left the arena a little after 1am
i slept about 20 minutes that whole
night
8 30 the next morning that's when i
found out that i had it
one of the scariest experiences of my
life
my biggest concern was i had just seen
my mother and my sister
four or five days before that and called
them my look you have to get tested
right away
i went back home and i had to separate
myself from my family
i'm in the basement by myself and
i have no windows in my basement you
don't know if it's 4 p.m or 4 a.m
it's monday will it come on tuesday
tuesday temperatures are saying well
come on wednesday wednesday we'll come
on thursday
and i was down there for for about 10-11
days
at the end of the day i'm 23. you know
i'm a kid and i
i still have fears obviously having the
virus i feel
a different way than most
[Music]
i wish people understood a little bit
more
once the nba shut down it felt like the
first domino had fallen and it was just
a matter of time
for every other domino to start falling
for the leagues to start saying
this is not safe march madness one of
the greatest spectacles in all of sports
has been knocked out and the four major
professional sports leagues in north
america
have been silenced for how long is
anyone's guess
the season just began off kilter
the tweet by the rockets gm uh about the
protesters in hong kong
and then we mourn the loss of david
stern the former commissioner
[Music]
and then on that sunday when we got the
news on kobe
it was
you're just empty
so people were already kind of in this
emotional vortex
and this emotional conflict when all of
a sudden
boom here's a pandemic
i don't think the gravity hit the
players until
there was the first positive test in in
the nba
it was just a really grave wake-up call
about what we were about to be
confronted with
[Music]
and then for that to be compounded by
then
having unprecedented level of racial
conversations
as we're talking about police violence
and institutional racism and systemic
oppression
in this situation where my humanity is
at stake or the humanity of my people is
at stake
do i want to be the entertainment right
now
[Music]
i think a big reason why this entire
conversation that we're having in this
country
is at the level that it is is because
there has been no sports to distract
anybody
it's because we have no choice but to
sit here and
and reflect we have a moment in time
people are going to look back our kids
are going to look back at this and say
you are a part of that
i'm glad it's something that's sparked a
newer conversation of having athletes
lead the charge having athletes
that are uh not just basketball players
but
that can you know lead and speak on the
issue intelligently
march 11th is the night that changed the
world forever i don't think it's just
basketball
i think it stopped the world in its
tracks it stopped our country in its
tracks
your love of team and your love of sport
and the game you've always played
is colliding with your love of family
and your love of
spouse and what's best
and there's not an easy answer in there
[Music]
i don't know if we're going to see games
played the way we've always seen games
played with
20 000 screaming fans
his sport's ever going to be the same
if i told you i knew that answer
i'd be lying too
you